[Music]
Queen Elizabeth II's cause of death
revealed when we think about her Legacy
it has to be one of Duty before self you
know I think she will long be remembered
as Elizabeth the Great
Elizabeth the steadfast she was quite
simply always there it's been three
weeks since the Monarch died at the age
of 96. the national records of Scotland
just published her death certificate
which reveals she passed of old age with
the Queen's time of death being around 3
P.M on September 8th Elizabeth
understood the importance of continuity
and so the vow that she made when she
was just 21 and South Africa to to
devote her entire life to duty whether
her life was long or short was something
that she absolutely did and she
fulfilled ET previously reported that
King Charles his wife Camilla and
Princess Anne were able to see her
before she died at her Scottish estate
Balmoral Castle as for the rest of her
family including Prince William and
Prince Harry they weren't able to make
it in time
since the Queen's death there's been an
outpouring of love her life celebrated
by millions the pop and Circumstance the
way the people waited in line for her
for 15 20 22 hours I met someone who
waited in line I'll never forget it and
the send-off that she gave the love that
was sent her way was very very special
to me one thing's for sure Queen
Elizabeth made an everlasting impact on
her country something that started at a
young age which it seems won't be
forgotten by her people I think the
nation fell in love with the young
Elizabeth and Margaret here were these
two beautiful princesses and this young
king and queen who'd come to the rescue
save the royal family stood by the
nation during the blitz I mean the Queen
Mother famously saying that she would
never leave Buckingham Palace and that
when it was bombed she famously said
when she went to visit the people of the
East End that she could look them in the
eye because it had been a great leveler
and I think that was something that
passed down to princesses Elizabeth and
Margaret that their people would always
come first and duty to their people is
what defined being Royal
[Music]